this boat survived its dangerous journey
across the Indian Ocean now beached on
the shores of Northern Indonesia for
weeks it was home to dozens of rohingya
traveling from refugee camps in
Bangladesh
your family is
they're escaping places like this
refugee camps in Bangladesh home to many
of the 1 million rohingya Muslims who
escaped persecution in Myanmar the group
who arrived in Atcher Province on Sunday
had been drifting at sea for a month
before their boat washed up near the
fishing Village of ladong
three of them are in a serious condition
but most of them experienced dehydration
that's why they are quite weak
the UN Refugee agency said over the
weekend that 180 refugees who left
Bangladesh in a boat in November were
now presumed dead the UN estimates the
number of rohingyas risking The Crossing
has increased by 500 percent this year
compared to 2021.
here we have
we have more people who who would need
to to seek safety and this is the point
we're trying to make we said when people
do not see that there are safe Pathways
for them to seek protection where there
is no hope for refugees at the end of
the tunnel we will sadly see more and
more people uh trying to take these
dangerous and risky Journeys we are
playing and asking for international
support to Bangladesh and local
authorities and communities but also on
the regional states that when they know
there is a boat out there with desperate
human beings need to being rescued there
they should act these refugees are lucky
in one respect they're still alive but
where they go from here is another
question Paul Reese Al Jazeera